gardez la france au fond des yeux
j'aimerais beaucoup qu'ils en apprennent
à tricoter d'accord là-dessus à votre
place je la ramène un peu moins mais si
vous ne réussissez pas c'est qu'il vous
manque qu'une seule chose un tout petit
détail le trophée des valises à paris de
ce qui lui arrive à la bulle
l'inattendu explore les archives du
palais bourbon cette semaine à quelques
jours des législatives
nous allons voir comment s'inscrit cette
institution au sein de notre république
bonjour à tous et bienvenue à
l'assemblée nationale
l'hémicycle c'est le lieu où le peuple
par l'intermédiaire de ses représentants
le peuvent dans cette diversité
s'exprime et qui mieux que jean louis
debré pour nous parler de l'assemblée
nationale bonjour monsieur le président
nous sommes ici chez vous c'est peu de
dire vous avez fréquenté le palais
bourbon plus de 20 ans en tant que
député en tant que président de
l'hémicycle mais aussi en tant qu enfant
cette salle des quatre colonnes c'était
votre salle de jeu c'est ça oui cette
maison je suis pas chez moi c'est la
maison des représentants du peuple mais
j'appartiens à une famille politique et
au lendemain de la guerre c'est tout
j'étais petit mes parents se
réunissaient régulièrement avec leurs
amis de
la résistance et puis quand vous avez 10
12 ans les conversations des grands ça
vous ennuie s'occuper il faut s'occuper
j'avais trouvé un système mais c'était
un autre monde je voulais que mes patins
à roulettes et avec un certain nombre
d'enfants d'huissier nous faisions des
partis et là je vous assure que quand
vous tournez ici et que vous repartez
fantastique mais ne le dit pas alors en
votre compagnie on va on va prendre le
pouls on va découvrir cette assemblée on
va parler des députés bien sûr pourquoi
il y en a t'il 577 on va également parlé
des femmes dans l'hémicycle enfin nous
reviendrons sur certains moments qui ont
marqué la vie du palais bourbon mais
d'abord le zapping de l'inattendu
[Musique]
alors monsieur bah on se défile toujours
le premier ministre deux fillettes de
vision ace de fines à l'assemblée
nationale le premier ministre que la
part dont dominique de villepin
touchés christine boutin s'effondre en
pleurs
saisissant la députée udf descend
affronter le premier ministre l
invective lionel jospin essor folle de
rage il est légitime que nos concitoyens
soient inquiets s'agissant des
autorisations qui ont été données en
matière d'exploration et d'exploitation
de gisements de gaz de shit de schiste
compte tenu des compte tenu des méthodes
fureur de la droite honte à vous des
missions clamait l'opposition qui outré
décidé de quitter l'hémicycle puisque
c'est par petits bouts que vous êtes va
mais
je vais essayer de vous répondre par
peuvent pas vu thi
les socialistes explose de colère il se
lève d'un bloc pour quitter l'hémicycle
j'attache supportable je repris des
contrôles par emilie je vous en prie a
fait sa mue j'avais ma famille
bonsoir wolfsburg
[Musique]
voilà quelques phrases qui ont marqué
l'histoire tandis que ludivine lopez
nous rejoint dans cette salle des quatre
colonnes lieu de contact entre les élus
et la presse à quelques jours des
législatives le palais bourbon pour
l'instant est plutôt vide ça ne va pas
durer jean louis debré voulu réagir à
ces images coup et on vient de voir on
vient de voir les images qui peuvent
surprendre mais qui me choque pas on est
rentré dans l'époque de la communication
et il faut faire un spectacle plus que
de longs discours et les parlementaires
l'ont compris tous les pays du monde
tous les parlements du monde ont des
moments d'agitation où l'on retient
l'attitude de certains donc il faut pas
juger le parlement à cela il faut juger
le parlement à sa façon de faire la loi
de rédiger des lois de voter des lois et
de contrôler l'action du gouvernement
alors la télévision et les journalistes
seront présents ici dans cette salle des
quatre colonnes où sont interviewés où
seront interviewés les nouveaux députés
il y en aura
577 le divine lopez un chiffre qui ne
doit rien au hasard 577 donc c'est le
nombre de députés à l'assemblée
nationale bon ils sont rarement un tous
présents dans l'hémicycle ont en tout
cas chacun a son siège
577 ce chiffre date de 1986 mais ça n'a
pas toujours été le même sous la vème
république la vème république est née
[Musique]
1958 la vème république est née nouvelle
constitution nouvelle assemblée
tout nouveau député leur nombre est fixé
à
179,2 de plus qu'aujourd'hui déjà le
palais bourbon est animée avec les
nouveaux élus on les a vus arriver
conscients de leurs responsabilités mais
souriant pour prendre contact avec les
lieux et les usages quatre ans plus tard
en 1962 première révolution
conséquence de la décolonisation le
nombre d'élus baisse et passe de 579 à
482 en france l'installation de la
deuxième assemblée de la vème république
a ranimé les travées de l'hémicycle du
palais bourbon et au palais bourbon les
sièges se font et se défont après 1962
le nombre de députés va repartir à la
hausse avec la réorganisation des
départements franciliens en 1967 et
lyonnais en 1973 l'assemblée compte 490
élu avec quelques originalités un père
et un fils son député monsieur louis
joxe député du rhône et pierre joxe
député de saône et loire il y aura aussi
des anonymes qui siégeront ensemble
messieurs paul et michel durafour
messieurs alain et robert andré vivien
mais il y aura surtout trois forts au
palais bourbon après 1973 peu de
mouvement dans l'hémicycle hormis un
siège supplémentaire il faudra attendre
1986 pour qu'un nouveau changement
s'opère
577 députés au lieu de 491 il a fallu
ajouter des sièges dans l'hémicycle
supprimer quelques travées équiper les
nouvelles places du système de vote
électronique
c'est une décision du président
mitterrand il augmente le nombre de
sièges à l'assemblée en même temps qu'il
instaure le scrutin à la proportionnelle
résultat la majorité de droite n'est pas
toute puissante et l'extrême droite
entre dans l'hémicycle
on bricole essentiellement aux
extrémités de l'hémicycle mais parfois
les menuisiers en quelques états d'âme 5
je pense que ce soit pour l'extrême
droite ça me dérange encore plus nous
mais premier ministre jacques chirac
supprime la proportionnelle sans revenir
sur le nombre de sièges de députés
depuis il n'a pas changé toujours 577
même si on a parfois du mal à s'en
rappeler
depuis aucune idée ya pas trop de mon
bonheur ne dépend pas du nombre de
députés beaucoup de députés disait cet
homme en 1993 et vous vous en pensez
quoi jean louis debré du nombre de
députés ce qu'il y en a trop je pense
que c'est pas le problème le problème
c'est que ces hommes et ces femmes qui
sont élus représentent le mieux possible
la france ces territoires d'outre-mer et
la diversité frantel c'est ça
l'important alors qu'il y en ait
485 177 ça a évolué en fonction des
époques l'important c'est que ces femmes
et ces hommes qui sont aisés de la
nation et conscience qu'ils représentent
la nation mais aussi la diversité
française ludivine ce nombre de députés
ce qu'il a souvent été remis en question
par le passé en tout cas c'est un sujet
un qui s'invitent régulièrement dans le
débat public par exemple en 2013 des
personnalités politiques de gauche comme
de droite remettait en question le
nombre de parlementaires députés et
sénateurs confondues c'était le cas du
député ps du lot et garonne matthias
fekl écoutez le pour réduire le nombre
de parlementaires aujourd'hui à environ
1000 parlementaire en france on peut
faire moins à une condition c'est de
renforcer les pouvoirs des
parlementaires qui resteront aujourd'hui
un parlementaire ça personne ne le voit
mais souvent il est obligé de bricoler
parce qu'il a des équipes beaucoup moins
important à ses yeux ses homologues pas
assez de moyens pas assez d qu'il vaut
mieux qu'il ait moins de parlementaires
mais que ceux qui sont en place et plus
de moyens c'est ce mois je crois tout à
fait à sa et donc 450 ça peut être 500
ça peut être 420 je sais pas il faut
regarder concrètement ce que ça donne
mais moi je suis tout à fait favorable à
cette proposition un parlement resserré
donc mais plus efficace c'est ce que
disait matthias fekl à l'époque en 2010
tête c'était aussi le projet manuel
macro il voulait réduire de 30% le
nombre de parlementaires c'était aussi
l'une des mesures réclamées par les
gilet jaune est discutée lors du grand
débat national en 2019 pourquoi est-ce
que ce sujet finalement est toujours
dans les discussions parce qu'on évite
d'aborder ainsi les vrais sujets la
vraie question est de savoir quel est le
pouvoir législatif
des députés et les sénateurs comment et
par quelle procédure ils peuvent
modifier la loi et comment et c'est ça
les grandes fonctions du parlement
aujourd'hui dans tous les pays du monde
comment mieux assurer le contrôle par le
parlement de l'exécutif c'est ça les
vraies questions en tout cas dans
quelques jours ce sont bien
577 députés qui seront élus
merci beaucoup le divine mais combien de
femmes siègeront dans l'hémicycle pour
les cinq prochaines années c'est le
sujet dont on va dont on va parler tout
de suite
[Musique]
bonjour géraldine en 2010 7 39% des
femmes ont été élues députées et c'est
un record c'est un record certains mais
on n'est pas encore au niveau de la
parité et cette assemblée nationale
historiquement composée d'hommes
majoritairement composée d'hommes peut
parfois ressembler à une arène de combat
de coqs ou les bonnes manières serait
resté coincé à l'entrée moqueries
insultes sexisme l'assemblée nationale
n'est pas épargnée dans la cour du
palais monsieur edouard herriot
président du parti radical
jean-louis marin
et puis des femmes des communistes et
des socialistes
et puis des femmes voilà comment étaient
présentés en 1945 les 33 premières
femmes élues députées quelques années
plus tard les femmes députées intrigue
toujours autant
1963 sexisme ordinaire de la part de
cette journaliste votre mari qui l'a
accepté sans difficulté que vous
exerciez ce mandat oui votre vie
familiale ne souffre-t-elle pas de votre
nouvelle activité parlementaire
je n'ai pas encore eu le temps de me
rendre bien compte du sexisme de la part
des journalistes mais aussi au sein même
de l'hémicycle parce que le fait d'être
une femme ça vous a gêné dans votre
carrière absolument pas
bien sûr il y a eu à vaincre un certain
nombre de mentalité à vaincre des
esprits retardataires des esprits
retardataires qui seront sans cesse
dénoncée il est vrai que
soit lorsque je suis en commission
soient lorsque je suis en séance voir
lorsque je préside une séance de
l'assemblée il m'arrive de recueillir
d'entendre des interjections qui sont
assez déplacé et en 2012 la scène est
filmée madame cécile duflot ministre de
l'égalité des territoires et du logement
monsieur le président le coûteux
mesdames et messieurs les députés mais
surtout messieurs visiblement des
sifflets qui font la une des médias mais
non contents de leur petit effet
certains députés persiste et signe elle
était très belle d'ailleurs madame
duflot ce jour là elle avait une très
belle robe était tout à fait souriant
des saignante et tout d'un coup
l'application phare maquette pic selon
fars s'en fout un an plus tard alors
qu'une députée à la parole un collègue
imitent les caquètements d'une poule on
se suffit mais qui sait qu'ici faits
connus en revanche moi j'ai pas une
poule 1 c'est bon cette fois c'en est
trop je pensais même pas que ça existait
un comportement comme celui là j'ai
compris que c'est parce que je suis une
femme en réaction tout les députés de
gauche décide de marquer le coup pour
dire stop en faisant une arrivée groupée
dans l'hémicycle de son côté le député
philippe le ray hauteur des bruits de
poule sera sanctionné avec un rappel à
l'ordre est privée d'un quart de son
indemnité pendant un mois même sanction
un an plus tard pour le député julien
ouvert en réaction à cet échange merci
au président merci madame le président
monsieur robert je fais un petit rappel
à l'ordre c'est madame la présidente a
fait un rappel à londres madame le
président malgré ces rappels à l'ordre
et ces sanctions le sexisme perdure il
touche aussi les journalistes politiques
qui décident de lancer une pétition en
2015 on s'est aperçu qu'on avait tout d
anecdotes alors pas sur des gestes
déplacés parce que ça c'est extrêmement
rare mais on avait tout d anecdotes
notamment sur des propos sexistes
déplacer des propos sexistes déplacer
jean louis debré pendant votre mandat de
2002 à 2007 est-ce que vous avez été
témoin de ce genre de comportement
sexiste j'ai été témoin comme partout
dans toute société
de personnages qui se conduisent bien et
d'autres qui se conduisent à
l'assemblée est à l'image souvent
d'une certaine société
heureusement c'est aujourd'hui de plus
en plus marginal
au fur et à mesure que l'hémicycle
devient un endroit où il ya hommes et
femmes à égalité on voit disparaître ses
propos il faut pas oublier que l'arrivée
des femmes qu'on le dit dans ce film à
l'assemblée nationale la chambre des
députés
c'est 1946 et il ya toute une culture
une question machiste bien il ya encore
des imbéciles et partout il ya encore
des machos partout même dans le
journalisme ou est ce que je veux dire
ne jugeons pas l'assemblée à quelques
propos malheureux il faut les interdire
il faut les sanctionner mais ce n'est
pas le lot quotidien à l'assemblée
nationale voilà géraldine on l'a vu dans
le sujet députés et journalistes
politiques sont victimes de sexisme mais
pas seulement il y en a d'autres où il y
en a d'autres il ya les assistantes
parlementaires en 2016 elle lance un
blog qui recensait les actes et les
paroles sexistes et machistes et la
parole se libère doucement parfois même
face caméra comme l'air en 2017 il ya
des noms de parlementaires qui circulait
entre collaboratrice parce qu'on savait
qu'il fallait pas prendre l'ascenseur
avec eux parce qu'ils se passer quoi
parce qu'il y avait un risque qui vous
colle une main aux fesses qu' il ya eu
des histoires et donc il y avait une
black list des mecs avec qui il fallait
pas trop prendre de risques c'est un
exemple un de sexisme ordinaire dans
l'enceinte même où des textes contre les
violences sexistes sont votés comment
faire pour faire cesser ces
comportements vous avez évoqué une piste
faire qui est autant d'hommes que de
femmes est ce qu'il ya d'autres choses à
faire plus concrètement au sein de
l'assemblée nationale pour que la parole
se libère et je trouve très bien mais ne
ne monteront pas seulement du doigt
l'assemblée nationale
la société d'air on le voit aujourd'hui
a foi dans le journalisme mais dans les
entreprises
mais ce que l'assemblée nationale n'a
pas valeur d'exemple c'est pour ça qu'on
doit être intransigeant qu'on doit être
transparent et que
on doit chasser tous ces comportements
c'est un combat contre la société
elle-même qui a des siècles à près d'un
siècle après siècle générer ce machisme
et bien nous sommes dans une nouvelle
ère où doit triompher
l'égalité le respect de l'homme par la
femme et de la femme par l'homme c'est
ça l'important et je crois que cette
maison qui a bien les emplois la mairie
côté est exemplaire doit l'être par le
fait de permettre à des hommes et des
femmes de travailler ensemble sans
ambiguïté monsieur le président on va
parler de ces débats législatifs qui
vous sont si chers merci beaucoup
géraldine
lead attendu vous le savez donc et cette
semaine à l'assemblée nationale camille
d'auxerre on a passé quelques portiques
de sécurité pour pour arriver jusqu'ici
ça s'est très bien passé
tout est fait en fait pour éviter des
intrusions l'assemblée nationale n'est
pas ouverte à n'importe exactement et
des intrusions il y en a eu ici à
l'assemblée en 1893 un anarchiste a même
réussi à entrer dans l'hémicycle et à y
lancer une bombe ça faisait d'ailleurs
la une du quotidien de paris mais parce
qu'à l'époque dans la salle des pas
perdus juste à côté les citoyens comme
nous pouvait y entrer venir rencontrer
leur député
l'assemblée était un lieu ouvert
aujourd'hui c'est bien différent par
exemple pour assister à la séance des
questions au gouvernement il faut soit
être invité par un député soit être
parmi les dix premières personnes
inscrites et la règle elle est clair
pour le public il faut être assis
découvert et se tenir en silence pas
toujours c'est ici qu'on vote les lois
pour le peuple mais où le peuple n'est
pas vrai monde bienvenue
s'est excité ce sont ces militants
contre le mariage pour tous dans les
tribunes le jour du vote de la loi en
2013 la tension est palpable
soudain une banderole réclamant un
référendum est déployée
bon sortez moi ces excités de
l'assemblée les ennemis de la démocratie
n'ont rien à faire dans l'hémicycle bon
drôle cris tout cela est interdit au
public de l'assemblée nationale mais
dont l'hémicycle les militants qui se
glissent parmi les spectateurs imposent
leur loi entrée en scène des
intermittents du spectacle en 2003 acte
1 la question celle d'un député ps à
propos des intermittents monsieur
aillagon acte 2 la réponse non celle du
ministre mais celles d'une partie du
public
trois intermittents tente de lire un
texte
du jamais vu aux questions d'actualité
acte 3 les accusations
le mot voyou est lâché la droite accuse
la gauche d'un coup monté ça s'engueule
s'envoient des noms d'oiseaux
l'intrusion de militants brise le cadre
police et de l'assemblée ces images sont
d'ailleurs si rare qu'à chaque fois
elles font l'ouverture du jt un incident
rare mais sans gravité un inconnu a
réussi à s'approcher de jean-pierre
raffarin
petit moment de panique il a été attrapé
par les pieds par les huissiers ça
paraît fou mais en 2002 cet homme déjoue
la sécurité de l'assemblée et s'approche
au plus près du premier ministre jean
pierre raffarin plus de peur que de mal
le moule et juste lui remettre une coupe
sportive mais prenons et la sécurité
n'est jamais en faillite ce matin déjà
une dizaine de militants de greenpeace
était parvenu à grimper sur les toits de
l'assemblée nationale en 2009 après
avoir pris d'assaut le toit du
palais-bourbon d'autres militants de
greenpeace entre dans l'assemblée et
tout d'un coup un déboulé de gendarmes
dans les couloirs du palais bourbon
sur le qui vive
ça sert à rien de pousser aussi monsieur
des gendarmes sur les dons car à
l'intérieur de l'hémicycle
une militante est en train de descendre
en rappel dans les tribunes des députés
une banderole est rapidement déployée où
l'on peut lire aux actes monsieur le
président à droite c'est la colère
l'indignation
ambiance volcanique
alors que les députés verts encourage
les perturbateurs vous avez vu le peu de
députés qui étaient présents bien grâce
à greenpeace aujourd'hui on parle de du
problème du climat le non l'a militons
descendu en rappel est l'invitée du 13
heures de france 2 on vous a accusé hier
d'utiliser des méthodes fascistes je
cite et de violer la démocratie qu'est
ce que vous répondez à cela je crois que
bien au contraire on ne viole pas la
démocratie on a choisi la maison du
peuple pour faire passer un message on
s'est dit mais rentrons dans l'hémicycle
allons prendre la parole à côté des
députés la maison du peuple un endroit
stratégique devant lequel convergent bon
nombre de manifestations et qui à chaque
fois est largement protégé par les
forces de l'ordre mais le temps des
grands entre régions semble derrière
nous jusqu'à la prochaine
on a vu ces images en 2003 jean louis
debré ou un homme approche jean pierre
raffarin qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce
jour là s'ils voulaient c'était la
rentrée parlementaire
et nouveau député rentrer raffarin monte
à la tribune pour faire son discours de
politique générale et à ce moment la vie
du monde et lui remet une coupe
l'enquète
qu'on a diligenté après dima n'est pas
possible
comment est-ce qu'il est rentré et moi
qui avait fait du patin à roulettes je
voyais tout à l'heure dans les couloirs
et sous sol j'ai montré comment on
pouvait rentrer d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
un peu plus rentrer d'accord mais ne dit
pas en l'occurrence en l'occurrence lé
enquête a montré qu'ils étaient pénétrer
dans cette maison grâce à la complicité
de la députée justement après cet
incident en 2003 vous avez demandé une
étude sur la sécurité des députés et
trois mois plus tard et bien la sécurité
est renforcée impossible de rentrer sans
être dûment badgé badge vert orange
jaune ou bleu estampillé sg ou h comme
hémicycle un hémicycle à l'axé désormais
restreint lorsque le parlement s'est
réuni il n'y a aucune exception même
avec moi depuis aujourd'hui donc le port
du badge est obligatoire pour tous alors
les huissiers dit on ont révisé en
trombinoscope leur a même été distribués
cet été
est ce que un badge ça suffit pour
sécuriser l'assemblée ce parc a pas que
le ballon et on a ici des hommes et des
femmes huissier remarquable qu'ils
apprennent à reconnaître les hommes les
femmes qui sont les élus les assistants
parlementaires
le ballon ne fait pas tout dans
l'histoire ya toujours eu des intrusions
vous avez rappelé l'attentât avec l'abbé
lemire m'est arrivé à d'autres
mais la résonance
était une résonance pas très grande
aujourd'hui imaginer les chaînes de
télévision la vôtre comme les autres
s'il ya le moindre incident ici ça
devient un événement mondial et ça
devient un argument pour contester la
légitimité des représentants du peuple
monsieur le président jean louis debré
mille merci de nous avoir accueillis
dans dans votre maison dans la maison je
la frangine j tellement vous voir en
train de patins à roulettes ici ça
serait extraordinaire écouter quand les
caméras seront terminés je vous
montrerai comme ça merci beaucoup
camille
[Musique]
voilà on va terminer cet inattendu à
l'assemblée nationale sur une pépite qui
est
je pense devrait vous rappeler quelques
bons souvenirs gardez vous permettez moi
très simplement de vous remercier de
vous adresser mes voeux à chacune et à
chacun d'entre vous et vous dire très
simplement aussi que cela restera
l'honneur de ma vie d'avoir présidé
l'assemblée nationale je vous remercie
devant merci
voilà jean louis debré c'était votre
derniers jours sur le perchoir dans dans
l'hémicycle oui et c'est vrai et
diablement l'honneur de ma vie parce que
j'aime tellement cette maison et j'aime
tellement la démocratie parlementaire
que l'avoir présidé aux débats ça a été
pour moi un moment exceptionnel et on
l'a bien on l'a bien constaté parce que
depuis le début de l'enregistrement de
cette émission tous les gens que nous
croisons vient de vous voir et vous
saluer chaleureusement parce que ce sont
mes amis parce qu'ils servent la
démocratie parlementaire et nous on se
retrouve pour servir france info la
semaine prochaine sur le canal 27
l'inattendu s'est aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux je souhaite france ce transfuge
de l'ina émission préparée avec nos
documentaliste merci à vous camille pour
ce sujet et merci bien sûr à toute
l'équipe et merci à vous qui êtes
présents chaque semaine à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]